[Music]
what is the most
amazing holiday you guys have been on
christmas
oh we're using holiday in the european
center vacation vacation i guess so
this is a european article damn holiday
holiday give me a vacation vacation yeah
on holiday i was gonna say easter you
said christmas
okay for me it was that one trip that we
were gone for almost a whole month we
went to
so many different places that was that
was the most amazing vacation
ever where'd you go we went to we had a
pit stop in istanbul and in london
but we went to paris for a couple days
and then we went to
morocco and then we went to croatia you
guys were gone for a month
that's a lot it was like three weeks we
actually we didn't plan
it out right because like we we had a
another trip to croatia after the
morocco trip but it came afterwards and
we were but it was like the morocco
yeah and then we actually came home for
like two hours no it was a little more
than that
but a couple hours but we came home from
four hours from
europe back and then went back
yeah well i saw some of the pictures
online i was like where the
[ __ ] were they at there was like some
like muslim stuff going on
like crazy beautiful yeah but that was
exhausting though because then one trip
was already planned and then the croatia
trip came afterwards so we already had
our flight set for that first trip
that's why we had to come to l.a
and it would be easier to just stay
there it would have been yeah when less
tiring too
but what abs that was my favorite
holiday would you guys ever
leave are you either review leaving
types
no no no so you would never like if you
had an amazing time at a resort or
whatever you want to be like
let me log on it was like mind blowing
to knock my socks off
yeah if it was like that i'd be like oh
they deserve a review because i know the
power of reviews
i reviewed my family that's it review of
your fans i'll review it to my family
personally i do it on my blog yeah i
review it on the vlog or i view it in
the tip
gotcha these guys really did a good job
on washing my dog here's like extra 30
bucks or something i don't know i do try
to review
airbnbs like whenever because especially
because they bug you so much they do bug
you they're like
can you hit us with a review like they
were great nancy was cool
like what was yeah what was her name so
nice what did they leave in the
refrigerator for me
how much toilet paper was there yes
that's all there yes and then when i
know that they reviewed me
i'm like okay then for sure i'm going to
review them and they review us too
yeah you'll get an email like so and so
left to review but you won't see it
until after you review
so i'm like i'm [ __ ] nosy i want to
know what they said so then i'm like
okay i'll give them a review because
then after that window's gone and you
can't review them but then you can see
their review and then i feel bad
that i didn't review i never got an
airbnb piece out
you've never been on airbnb i never got
it myself i always beg somebody to do it
for me and i pitch
oh yeah yeah that's nice that's actually
me she's she's my go-to airbnb
person i got my my past airbnb is on my
airbnb
it's kind of nice to see where you went
to and if you can change it
you just send it to a friend if you're
like oh you went here go check stay at
this place
true true yeah have you guys left
because these are all like
positive uh reviews have you guys left
negative ones either like
i think people unless it was really if
they were like sketch
i'm doing it to warn others um but not
not for my own personal like [ __ ] you
guys like i don't got time
we did it as a group a negative review
korean barbecue spot yeah
yeah and a seafood restaurant and we did
another one
yeah that's a lot we did a couple of
them yeah we were treated poorly though
like they hated us being there we
weren't even being like bad customers
the restaurant's done now
like it was across from drips and swirls
the part
it's called like la family but it didn't
feel like a family well i guess it did
if you had dysfunctional family
true so like it was true yeah it's like
it's called the l.a family korean
barbecue
it was they gave us like rotted garlic
and when we complained
they were mad at us and then they were
like asking for water
and then they were like oh my god and
then they pointed at the sign
like we reserved the right to refuse
service or something because we didn't
leave it well because we didn't leave
them any tip
and they were like yo like they expected
the tip and we're like [ __ ] we asked you
like five times for all kinds of things
and you guys are acting foul yeah but we
i mean i'm not a reviewer
in general but that was like one of the
one and only reviews i've ever left
because it was just so bad i'm not a big
reviewer either good or bad
yeah sure me neither it's too much work
unless there's like a personal
connection with somebody well that's why
you bring up personal
because here's a review where things get
a little personal
uh this guy named michael he left the
review on tripadvisor
and the beginning it starts off very
nice
you would won't be wondering why he left
a one star rating
at the palms uh in turks and kaikos
all right so this is like a you know
very a nice resort white sand beaches
you know like drinking all that stuff
right he goes
my wife and i went to this resort
beautiful resort
water sand pool service amazing we had
such a good time that i
the husband decided to fly home to get
our son tom to enjoy it also
whoa damn baller when i returned
things seemed awkward my wife eventually
told me that she went to a massage
while i was picking up our son and the
masseuse
seduced her and spent the night with her
i'm not blaming the resort for this
this is my wife's fault but just know
that this is the kind of thing that can
happen
at this resort oh [ __ ] one star
[ __ ] off is that the resort's fault
no one started wait would you give a one
star rating to the results uh he's just
mad my dude's just mad and and who who
blames him for being mad the massage guy
probably seduced the hotel to give him a
job
the massage guy is a seducer his wife
don't put five stars because she goes
i haven't had bomb dick in so
long when they give you that extra
service this service was so
good i never had this anywhere not even
morocco like funny
not only that if the wife is down to do
this during the vacation on your little
hot spot of going
in and out she's that reckless this
ain't her first
time doing anything like this like she's
already
empowered to do some crazy [ __ ] i want
to know how the wife explained this to
the husband like
he seduced me like i just i don't know
like i just fell honey look at him
and then he sees them he's like [ __ ]
you're right
[ __ ] this place i know it's like salt
bae and [ __ ] but [ __ ] even buffalo
maybe maybe then it's the resort's fault
right because it's a sexy man
why do you hire such sexy dudes maybe
he's warning other people like
hey man don't bring your wife here
because this guy is fun as [ __ ] don't
leave your wife here maybe it's for the
resort that like that's why
the rich women want to come to this
resort oh
like that one star was like oh yeah i'll
get the freak on
on the weekend when the husband's
golfing or some [ __ ] they're good so
there's other wives reading the reviews
going oh you see that one star rating
100 in here what if it's like all code
it's all like uh it's like their secret
code to be like this is the spot for
once this is a corny housewife to go to
exactly maybe that's funny
resort is fun no the resort has not
responded yet i don't think they need to
at this point i don't think they should
yeah it seems like a personal matter
now lately all right is this in the
caribbean yeah it's in the caribbean
yeah turks and caicos
i overlooked it
that's by the bahamas
who knows i've never been there me
neither but let's go let's get massages
let's see what let's see
let's try our luck and would you go for
a male uh therapist then
just to see what this woman was up
against i'm usually just like female
therapists only even though it's just
in my mind i request females okay yeah
so if someone presented you with a guy
you'd be like
no no no no go back well you did say you
like relaxation i know relaxation but if
the guy's doing it then
you're expecting more of like we're
going in i used to be the same
i was like man only ladies right and at
one time
they ran out of ladies and then i was
like i requested a lady and it was like
a chinese place you know they don't like
really listen to you so like this guy
came up and he was like
no and i was like nah i'm not ready for
this and he went
like this and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah
hold me
yeah did you see him with me yeah as i
was thinking i was like
he just got me like this and then i i
don't know man i felt like that dog i
was like but one time
i uh i got this dude and he was putting
like some oil on me on my back right
and then when he went like this with
this forearm i felt all of his hairs
going hair started off you're not wet
and i'm like oh i don't know man that
thing gotta stick with girls
sometimes their their hands are just
more uh like the skin on their hands
oh it's like rough rough yeah and like i
that kind of bothers me too like
i need a a woman's hand that is not
rough either and i need it to be soft
and like and that that's i don't know
it's like in my mind i'm psychologically
activated for a massage i think half the
massage is psychological
really i think half of it like it
doesn't actually benefit your
body that much more like i think have
it's like a mental
cause that's sad [ __ ] i'd rather have it
with a girl that i'm gonna [ __ ] after
but then the the actual like i'm sore
man i need your help
yeah i still feel like i need another
massage when i get it from a lady
oh i know what you mean because like and
also uh blunt hand like the thick blunt
hands
it's it doesn't hurt like uh like a like
a
lady's hands it feels like it's sharp
like the difference is needles it's like
a needle as opposed to like
yeah yeah yeah one's like a hammer and
one's like a knife yeah i classify them
differently too there's like for me
there's like relaxation massage
like tickle my balls massage there's
like sports massages
you know aunt he comes and he gives like
sports massage oh yeah it's like a
sports therapy massage yeah i'm like i'm
an athlete you need to fix me
and then that's way different and that
one i'm screaming all the time
and i'm [ __ ] uh my ears are turning
red i don't feel so good after yeah and
there's the other one where it's like
more relaxation and
always feels way better that's true like
i'd like a lady to caress my head
for quite a while yeah but i did have
this other experience
where they swapped in the middle of my
massage
what yeah it was the weirdest [ __ ]
experience
that's horrible you start with the lady
right and then like she gets on the
phone and i'm like man why is this [ __ ]
on the phone and [ __ ] it sounds all like
i'm like ruining my [ __ ] zen right
and then
you know she comes back and then i'm
like oh there she goes there she goes
and then i'm like man she smell like
cigarettes dude did she go have a
cigarette break or what
and i turn around and i see this
dangling ass gold chain and this [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] massaging my hating switch
i'm like you switched me man that's
illegal
that's illegal that's a fraternity
brother [ __ ] out of [ __ ] parts
coming another guy coming in what's
going on yeah
but i was like maybe she just had an
emergency or something you know you like
to see the good people yeah i was like
[ __ ] it dude did you ask for a refund
yeah
he was good it wasn't an upgrade though
yeah like the quality of the massage
he was good yeah i just i to me i was
expecting the lady that
came first yeah i started it and then i
mean the only problem was he smelled
like cigarettes man
that's not cool i don't want cigarettes
with my lavender i need a spa
you know that's the thing i think that
the smell
the cucumber water the little tranquil
sound going on
the whispering even though there's only
two people there the whispering
i know there's only two of us here don't
you feel like you
if you paid that money you kind of
deserve that kind of
quality yes because i'd be getting like
dollar massages you know forty dollars
and if it's gonna smell like cigarettes
i'm like well
this is the experience yeah yeah but if
you're paying like a hundred two hundred
i'd be pissed
you'd be pissed you can't do no
cigarettes yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you